Truman once it
manfred Reddick is in charge of the
building site he has lots of experience
managing big construction projects but
this is a very special job you know the
foundation he works for is responsible
for this huge project in the heart of
Berlin rebuilding Berlin's
city palace is currently the biggest
cultural construction project in Germany
80 million euros of the costs are to be
covered by donations collected by a
private sponsoring association unusual
preconditions for such a project
despendo comment we've received enough
donations to realize all the natural
stone work on the cupola we'll need
other components like the lanterns on
top but I can mount them later with a
mobile crane for me it was important to
go ahead and realize the entire
load-bearing structure the city palace
is being rebuilt smack dab in the
historic city centre
it's slated to be opened under the name
Humboldt forum in 2019 the old baroque
facades will be replicated just as the
architect andreas schlüter designed the
more than 300 years ago
rebuilding the ruins will cost 590
million euros and Germany's federal
government will pay the lion's share
when he walks through his construction
site
Manfred Rettig sees in his mind's eye
how it's going to look when it's
completed but politicians keep coming up
with new ideas that alter the finished
concept you thought you have stories let
me be very clear if you want to change
something like this plan then you're
throwing away a lot of money the
planning for these language labs that
are foreseen for the central and
regional library just the planning
already cost more than 5 million euros
your knowledge will be [ __ ]
but the palace itself is not all that's
being built beneath it a new subway line
is under construction so far the new
museum Island subway station exists only
as a model one day the subway will run
directly below the spra canal at a depth
of 22 meters the station has already
been designed but reality keeps placing
stones in its path literally the finding
of I advise him of Amitabh Oda was about
4 meters by 4 meters long what kind of
course that removing it cost us 8 weeks
or 2 months and a million euros just to
get this stone out of the way I love
them Victor one that come on first so
you can imagine if we build a tunnel 2
kilometers long and find 10 boulders and
we'll have to spend 10 million euros
more than others for my theme new young
males begin the ensemble of buildings on
Berlin's museum Island is a UNESCO World
Cultural Heritage Site in the middle of
it all Italian architect Franco Stella's
design for the new city palace combines
old and new
the builders are challenged by the
islands extremely sandy soil and high
ground water though I'm project mostly
plan on the plans for a project like
this have to be complete before you
begin building we're on an island see
all the water and so the substructure
has to be finished and the foundation
pit seal before you start on the
building long before other lands on the
board ago start with you with an only to
risk management we've completed the
shell construction that with us project
and we're still in the black no cost
overruns when the moment midnight Robson
Thyra - dude that can't be taken for
granted with massive construction
projects so far the city palace is
proceeding on schedule and within budget
but of course the reconstruction isn't
finished yet